guten tag liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz das ist
normalerweise eine veranstaltung von
journalistinnen für journalistinnen
inzwischen gruppen und sehr viele
menschen mehr zu
deswegen kurz die erklärung die
bundespressekonferenz ist eine
nichtstaatliche und unabhängige
organisation von menschen die aus der
hauptstadt berichten wir haben eine enge
zusammenarbeit mit dem vor allem der
auslandspresse dessen menschen also
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
aus dem ausland die aus berlin berichten
dass nutzer erklärung ich begrüße unsere
gäste heute
ich begrüße den bundesminister für
gesundheit gehen sparen
ich begrüße professor doktor susanne
herold leiterin der abteilung
infektiologie des uniklinikums gießen
professor dr
lothar wieler ist da präsident des
robert koch institutes dr andreas gassen
vorstandsvorsitzende der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung sowie
professor dr
uwe janssens präsident der deutschen
vereinigung für intensiv und
notfallmedizin dankenswerter weise
werden wir an dieser stelle vom
fernsehsender phoenix unterstützt was
das gebärdendolmetscher angeht befristet
deswegen eine karosse und badezimmer
er liebe frau welt sie meine damen und
herren zuerst einmal entschuldigung für
die leichter verspätung aber dass
corinna kabinett ging etwas länger als
geplant
sehr geehrte damen und herren die
politik die gesellschaft das
gesundheitswesen das leben von neben von
uns von allen bürgerinnen und bürgern
wird gerade bestimmt sehr bestimmt durch
die krone krise die politik ist im
krisenmodus die bürgerinnen und bürger
erleben die tiefsten einschnitte in die
freiheiten in den bürgerlichen
freiheiten in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik und ärzte und
pflegekräfte und alle die in den
medizinischen berufen arbeiten bereiten
sich auf die wohl größte herausforderung
in 75 jahren vor
wir haben schon viele infizierte in
deutschland und wir beklagen auch schon
viele tote aber noch ist das die ruhe
vor dem sturm
keiner
kann genau sagen was in den nächsten
wochen kommt damit unser
gesundheitssystem diese
herausforderungen meistert müssen wir es
schaffen die ausbreitung des virus die
zahl der infektionen zu verlangsamen und
wir müssen es schaffen in diesem
zeitraum gleichzeitig die intensiv
kapazitäten und die
behandlungsmöglichkeiten in den
krankenhäusern zu erhöhen
ich nehme wahr aus vielen gesprächen und
auch die länder sind dort sehr aktiv
alle 16 bundesländer wir sprechen das
immer auch in der täglichen schalte dass
das bemühen darum die intensiv
kapazitäten in deutschland zu verdoppeln
sehr sehr groß ist dass viele häuser
viele länder konzeptionell daran
arbeiten und dort auch viel kraft zeit
und ressourcen investiert werden um das
möglich zu machen hat der deutsche
bundestag gestern auch ein gesetz zu
entsprechenden finanzierung der
krankenhäuser auch in dieser lage
verabschiedet eine weitere stärke und
einen weiteren zeitgewinn haben wir
nicht zuletzt auch durch die große zahl
der testung das ist ja heute schon ein
anderer städte gesagt worden
wir haben zwischen drei und 500.000
tests in der letzten woche in
deutschland gehabt das dürften die
meisten tests in einem land auf der
ganzen welt seien absolut und in
relativer zahl
das zeigt die stärke unseres
gesundheitssystems auch in dieser
wichtigen frage
es macht es uns aber auch möglich sehr
viel frühzeitiger als es vielleicht
anderen ländern möglich gewesen ist
jetzt eben auch vorbereitungen zu
treffen weil wir eben entsprechende
sensorik schon sehr früh auch hatten und
diese zeit wollen wir jetzt auch nutzen
daran arbeiten alle vor ort und wir in
der bundesregierung tag und nacht und
das zu erklären um zu erklären wie wir
gegen das virus kämpfen und wie wir uns
vorbereiten bin ich sehr froh dass
einige hier mit mir heute auch sie
informieren das ist der präsident
unseres robert-koch-instituts der die
aktuellen zahlen nochmal darstellt und
einordnet das ist der vorsitzende der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung es
gab einige änderungen in der frage auch
wer getestet wird wir haben sehr sehr
viele tests ist aber auch wichtig dass
die tests zielgerichtet sind damit wir
tatsächlich eben auch für uns alle einen
entsprechenden mehr
daraus haben und ich finde es wichtig
dass wir auch das noch mal ihr
miteinander erläutern frau professor
herholz wird aus dem klinikalltag auch
als junge ärztin berichten welche
therapien es gibt und welche eher
aussichten und der präsident der
intensiv und notfallmedizin er professor
janssens wird uns berichten können auch
für die intensivabteilung die kliniken
sich untereinander austauschen und
vorbereiten auf das was uns erwartet als
politik stecken wir viel zeit in das
tagesaktuelle krisen-management wir
sorgen dafür oder die frage stellen wir
uns wie sorgen wir dafür dass
krankenhäuser vertragsärzte dass
pflegeeinrichtungen diese epidemie
finanziell stemmen können viele im
gesundheitswesen wie auch in anderen
bereichen in deutschland sind ja von
einem tag auf die andere auf den anderen
vor die frage gestellt wie es für sie
auch wirtschaftlich weiter geht wie wir
das auffangen können und sicherheit
geben können aber vor allem auch die
frage wie schaffen wir effizientere
strukturen und welche veränderungen wir
eben im alltag brauchen um die
infektions kurve abzuflachen die
verbreitung des virus zu verlangsamen es
sind ja genau die maßnahmen die auch in
den letzten tagen und wochen getroffen
wurden und die wir alle in unserem
alltag spülen
eine frage die uns natürlich auch sehr
beschäftigt ist die frage nach
schutzausrüstung und ausstattung um
diejenigen zu schützen die jeden tag
helfen die an der front in der pflege
als ärztinnen und ärzte im
gesundheitswesen arbeiten die eben keine
heimarbeit kein home office machen
können sondern jeden tag für uns im
einsatz sind das sind alles fragen an
denen wir gerade im bundesministerium
für gesundheit mit hochdruck arbeiten
jetzt aber abschließend eines wichtig
dass wir darüber nicht vergessen es wird
auch eine zeit nach corona geben und es
wird eine zeit geben in der wir noch
gegen das virus kämpfen aber in der das
leben sich wieder schrittweise
normalisiert denn der stillstand den wir
jetzt sehen die einschränkungen der
freiheit vieler bürgerinnen und bürger
die wir jetzt sehen die einschränkungen
öffentlichen leben die sind notwendig um
die verbreitung des virus zu
verlangsamen um vor allem auch
unsere intensiv kapazitäten sich
vorbereiten zu lassen und nicht zu
überfordern
in den kliniken und gleichzeitig braucht
es und diese zeit wollen wir haben
nutzen auch konzepte wenn wir uns nach
ostern ja mit dem ministerpräsidenten
und der bundesregierung mit der frage
beschäftigen wollen wo stehen wir mit
den maßnahmen wie geht es weiter mit
konzepten beschäftigen die er für dann
auch wichtig sind nämlich die frage die
wir besonders gefährdete gruppen
schützen pflegen und gut versorgen
ältere hochbetagte menschen mit
vorerkrankungen oder auch wie wir mit
maßnahmen die diskussionen brauchen da
bin ich sehr dafür die dann aber eben
auch eine umsetzbarkeit brauchen wir
etwa die frage wie wir handy daten und
digitale informationen nutzen können wie
in südkorea um dann infektionsketten
auch sehr schnell nachvollziehen zu
können ob und wie wir das in einem
solchen absoluten krisenfall wie den den
wir jetzt haben nutzen wollen oder nicht
diese gesellschaftliche debatte braucht
es aus meiner sicht denn wir stehen die
möglicherweise vor der frage ob wir
bestimmte freiheiten des wahltages
leichter zurückbekommen können wenn es
gleichzeitig möglich ist sehr sehr
schnell infektionsherde neue ausbrüche
neuer infektionsketten zu erkennen und
dann auch entsprechend zu beenden
all diese dinge beschäftigen uns jeden
tag und deswegen bin ich dankbar dass
wir viel an unserer seite haben die uns
dabei helfen und ich bin sehr dankbar
dafür dass wir sie gemeinsam heute
informieren
ja meine damen und herren herzukommen
ankurbelt 19 können alle menschen in
deutschland erkranken unabhängig vom
alter und umland kam ich vom
gesundheitszustand aber je älter man ist
desto höher ist das risiko dass die
krankheit schwer verläuft oder dass wir
an dieser krankheit zu über sterben
können
das heißt auch dass jüngere und gesunde
menschen sehr schwer erkranken können
das passiert selten aber es kann
passieren dass eben auch jüngere und
gesunde menschen daran sterben können
das sehen wir ja bereits in unseren
nachbarländern und je mehr menschen in
deutschland erkranken desto
wahrscheinlicher wird ist dass wir
solche fälle eben auch in deutschland
sehen darum nochmal
sehr deutlich gesagt hier stehen gerade
am anfang die epidemie gegner zu
bekämpfen und die zahlen werden weiter
steigen und wir sind wirklich alle
gefragt mitzumachen um diese epidemie zu
bekämpfen darum nochmal kurz erläutert
die drei säulen unserer
bekämpfungsstrategie erster die
eindämmung fälle von kogit 19 müssen
schnell identifiziert werden und
isoliert werden die kontakte müssen
nachverfolgt werden und unter quarantäne
gestellt werden
dazu brauche test kapazitäten dazu
brauchen wir ein gesundheitsamt das
maximal unterstützt ist in der aufgabe
infekt ketten so schnell wie möglich zu
erkennen und dann eben zu brechen und
dazu gehört auch dass wir eben abstand
halten das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges
gebot dass wir in diesen tagen und
wochen einhalten sollen
das zweite ist der schutz derjenigen die
schutz brauchen die wir als wohl noch
alle gruppen benennen minister sparen
hatte die sie eben auch angesprochen und
das dritte die dritte wichtige säule ist
die versorgungskapazitäten zu erhöhen
sowohl bei den niedergelassenen auch bei
den kliniken um co mit 90 patienten zu
behandeln
in den kliniken müssen die
beratungskapazitäten mindestens
verdoppelt werden das fordern wir und
wenn es mehr geht dann natürlich ist das
umso besser je mehr beatmungs sätze wie
in unserem land vor halten desto mehr
menschen leben werden wir retten und ich
das noch mal gerne zu der säule 1 und 2
zum eindämmung und zum schutz der
lokalen gruppen da können wir alle
beitragen das müssen wir auch tun
und das tun wir am besten wir abstand
halten sozial natürlich keinen aufstand
sondern einen physischen abstand halten
wenn wir zu hause bleiben wenn wir krank
sind und dann auch zu hause abstand
halten
kurz eine lage darstellung nur ganz kurz
weltweit haben wir heute mehr als 385
1000 fälle offiziell gemeldet bekommen
datenstand des europäischen center for
disease control am 25 dritter um 10 uhr
das waren 36 1000 fälle mehr als am
vortag
der anteil der verstorbenen lag hier bei
4,8 prozent und in der europäischen
union dem europäischen wirtschaftsraum
inklusive des vereins
königsreichs haben wir zu diesem
zeitpunkt rund 174.000 fälle und das
waren 20.000 100 fälle mehr als am
vortag
sie interessiert sich ja vor allen
dingen die epidemiologische situation in
deutschland
und die ist der status vom 26
30 uhr zu diesem zeitpunkt wurden uns
elektronisch übermittelt von den
entsprechenden gesundheitsämtern und
landesbehörden in deutschland rund
36.500 fälle das waren rund 5000 fälle
mehr als am vortag
unter diesen fällen wurden insgesamt 198
todesfälle vermeldet damit ist die
gesamte incidents das ist die anzahl der
fälle pro 100.000 einwohner in
deutschland auf 44 fälle gestiegen
sie stärkt sie variiert stark in
deutschland und darauf weiß ich auch
immer wieder gerne hin
das heißt dass man eben auch in
bestimmten regionen in deutschland auch
unterschiedliche intensiv dagegen
angehen muss und auch strategisch
darüber nachdenken muss in hamburg zb
waren es zu dem zeitpunkt 69 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner in bayern 61 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner in
mecklenburg-vorpommern 15 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner
also es gibt regionale unterschiede und
das wird auch während der nächsten
wochen und monate so bleiben wie das und
wohl die stadt entwickelt können wir
nicht sagen aber wir wissen auch wir
schätzen dass mindestens 5900 mitbürger
und mitbürgerinnen inzwischen genesen
sind und das ist auch eine gute
nachricht
wie sieht das profil derjenigen aus die
erkrankt sind datenstand 26 30 uhr die
betroffenen personen sind im
durchschnitt 46 jahre alt das heißt also
diejenigen die gemeldeten elektronisch
gemeldet wurden die verstorbenen waren
im durchschnitt momentan 81 jahre alt
männer 54 prozent der fälle 56 prozent
der fälle sind frauen also nach wie vor
sind männer häufiger betroffen von kogit
19 als frauen und für einen großteil der
fälle
liegen uns klinische informationen
vornehmlich für mehr als 26 tausend
fälle
die häufigsten symptome husten fieber
meine damen und herren das robert koch
institut wird weiter wie lange auch
diese krise dauern wird systematisch
berichten systematisch analysieren und
systematisch jeden tag für jede region
das risiko bewerten und damit wir das
tun können brauchen wir natürlich
information und die erhalten wir so gut
es geht und wir stellen alle diese
informationen die wir haben transparent
auf unserem dashboard zur verfügung ich
bitte also alle die die information
detailliert kennenlernen müssen möchten
auf unser dashboard zu gehen wo wir
jeden tag um 0 uhr aktive zahlen
grafiken und alles einstellen so dass
wirklich jeder bürger bis auf
landkreisebene
die zahlen die wir offiziell gemeldet
bekommen von den landkreisen und den
gesundheitsämtern nachvollziehen kann
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann noch keine
sichere aussage dazu gemacht werden ob
sich die infektions dynamik insgesamt
abschwächt wir sehen das weiter sehr
viele fälle neu diagnostiziert werden
und gemeldet werden es gibt allerdings
nach wie vor starke regionale
unterschiede zwischen den bundesländern
und landkreis und einzelne kreise sind
eben besonders stark betroffen manche
städte und landkreise haben es geschafft
auch größere ausbruchsgeschehen bereits
unter kontrolle zu bekommen
und das darf auch nicht aufhören die
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienste die
gesundheitsämter sollten wir maximal
unterstützen damit sie ihre arbeit
machen können aber aktuell kämpft der
öffentliche gesundheit geht es gegen
viele einzelne ausbruchsgeschehen die im
zusammenhang mit festen oder reisen in
den letzten wochen aufgetreten sind
warum immer noch feste gefeiert werden
ist mir unverständlich
es steht zu hoffen dass derartige
geschehen durch die eingeleiteten
maßnahmen künftig weniger werden
das fordern wir und jeder trägt
verantwortung dafür diese maßnahmen auch
durchzuhalten
allerdings werden wir auch zunehmend
ausbrüche in alten und pflegeheimen und
krankenhäusern berichtet und das ist
sicher besorgniserregend denn hier sind
besonders
empfindliche und wohlhabende menschen
betroffen hier brauchen wir höchste
aufmerksamkeit
wir haben gestern als eine strategische
maßnahme so wie wir das seit wochen tun
immer angepasst an die situation
die testkriterien angepasst nach denen
ärzte entscheiden sollen welche
patienten auftritt 19 getestet werden
und welche nicht
wir haben das ist korrekt eine sehr hohe
des kapazität in deutschland und das ist
gut so und das hat uns auch geholfen die
epidemie frühzeitig zu erkennen
aber trotzdem müssen wir gezielt testen
herr gassen wird das sicher gleich noch
genau ansprechen ich möchte nur
folgendes sagen
generell sollten nur menschen getestet
die symptome zeigen und dann soll
ausschlaggebend sein ob sie kontakt zu
einem bestätigten fall 19 fall hatten ob
sie zu einer risikogruppe gehören oder
ob sie zum personal das mit zum
medizinischen personal gehören oder ob
sie schwer an harmonie erkrankt sind
also eine lungenentzündung und es keine
andere differenzial diagnostik gibt das
ist so viel von meiner seite dankeschön
vielen dank herr professor wähler hat
schon auf einige aspekte hingewiesen
die frage die sie wahrscheinlich auch
bewegt ist wie stehen wir im vergleich
zum internationalen ausland warum sieht
es bei uns noch vergleichsweise gut aus
sicherlich ist ein aspekt dass wir
wahrscheinlich als einzige
gesundheitssysteme tatsächlich auf die
gesamte unserer bevölkerung auch
eingestellt sind das heißt wir erhalten
versorgung für 83 millionen forum nicht
nur für teile davon und wir haben eine
starke niedergelassene ärzteschaft die
den krankenhäusern sozusagen
vorgeschaltet ist in der versorgung der
patienten
damit ihr das tun können haben wir viele
dinge schon bewegt wir haben
widerspricht ungeöffnet wir haben
abrechnungsmöglichkeiten für tests
geschaffen und das zu einem sehr frühen
zeitpunkt das führt eben dazu dass wir
in der lage sind testung in deutlich
höherer takt zahlen um den usa um
fälligkeit zu durchzuführen als dass die
meisten anderen länder sind um ihnen da
mal gleich eine vorstellung zu geben wir
haben in der
seit dem neunten märz 410.000 testungen
durchgeführt in großbritannien waren das
100000 in den zeiträumen also es wurde
bereits angesprochen die empfehlung des
rk ii zu den sitzungen hat sich geändert
und angepasst war das ist auch richtig
und sinnvoll wir müssen natürlich im
fortschreiten der erkrankung und auch
immer wieder neu orientieren und von
daher ist es vollkommen richtig zu sagen
es macht keinen sinn gesunde
unauffällige bürger zu testen
auch wenn das für den 1 vielleicht
interessant sein kann bringt das ist es
medizinisch sinnfrei und wir haben auch
die kapazitäten
es war ein großer anzahl fahren aber
auch nicht um 83 millionen einfach mal
durch zu testen und deshalb gibt es eine
entsprechende symptome konstellation die
das ak ihnen empfehlungen festgelegt hat
letztendlich wird die entscheidung im
test durchführen und muss sie auch
ärztlich indiziert sind das heißt die
erste vor ort entscheiden
das ist glaube ich die wichtigste
botschaft die ärztliche entscheidungen
test durchführen ist relevant und nicht
die patient oder ein vermeintlicher
patient den wunsch danach verspürt weil
auch nur so testet sinnvoll
adjustiert werden können also nochmal
haben keine ausweitung von testkriterien
sondern wir haben eine präzisierung wir
können große mengen von tests
durchführen ich habe schon von den
zahlen gesprochen und haben eine test
kapazität die mittlerweile bei über
einer viertelmillion tests pro woche
liegt damit ist es möglich die fälle die
in den empfehlungen des rki adressiert
werden zu testen
wir können das auch sehr schnell wir
können das mit einer hohen präzision
wir können das bis auf wahrscheinlich
360.000 testungen in der woche steigern
das ist sicherlich auch kein
selbstläufer ist der tatsache geschuldet
dass wir mehr als 86 labore in der
vertrag selbst schafft angeschlossen
haben die zum teil rund um die uhr das
muss man erstellt glaub ich auch mal
erwähnen mit ihrem personal diese test
betriebe überhaupt ermöglichen
selbst bei dieser hohen zahl von testen
können sich aber vorstellen ist das
natürlich trotzdem eine ressource die
sinnvoll appliziert sein muss zumal ich
auch nicht nur an den test kapazitäten
der maschinen hängen sondern auch an den
reagenzien die in diesen maschinen voran
sein müssen
und da haben wir sicherlich immer einen
gewissen vorrat aber er ist auch
irgendwann endlich und er ist auch schon
deshalb endlich weil diese reagenz
den weltweit nur von ganz wenigen
herstellern produziert werden das sind
internationalen lieferketten und sie
können sich vorstellen
nicht nur in deutschland wird getestet
sondern überall so dass es zum teil zur
rationierung durch die hersteller kommt
und das ist ein weiterer grund warum wir
auch hier mit unseren test kapazitäten
schonend und sinnvoll umgehen müssen
neben den test limitierungen durch
reagenzien und maschinenkapazität und
personalkapazitäten ist ein weiteres
problem auch die frage der
schutzbekleidung völlig logisch wenn sie
viel testen wollen dann müssen sie viel
test entnahmen durchführen dafür
brauchen sie schutz materialien
das ist auch weltweit das gleiche
problem die sind maximal nachgefragt die
vorräte die die vertragsärzte
routinemäßig auch für influenza fälle
angeschafft haben sind natürlich von der
anbrandenden zahl acht fälle sind ja
nicht alles bestätigte fälle
aufgebraucht worden jetzt ist es deshalb
gut und richtig dass auch das bmg in die
beschaffung eingestiegen ist und wir
jetzt gott sei dank auch feststellen
dass tatsächlich materialien an kommen
beispielsweise ffb zahl masken die sind
ja nun ganz wesentlich um eine
übertragung auszuschließen
und der bedarf ist erheblich von daher
muss man sagen wir versuchen das ganze
möglichst niederschwellig zu ermöglichen
die kv als verteilzentrum also die
regionalen kassel die vereinigung stehen
24 stunden sieben tage die woche bereit
um materiellen anzunehmen und dann auch
zu diskutieren denn wir müssen natürlich
auch schauen wo gehen diese masken hin
hier gibt es gewisse priorisierung die
einzuhalten sind
aber es ist ganz entscheidend dass wir
diesen strom an schutz materialien
beibehalten können damit es nicht zu
praxisschließungen kommt sie haben
berlin als beispiel heute schon hören
und über 100 praxen sind bereits
geschlossen zum teil durch
quarantänemaßnahmen zum teil auch weil
sie einfach keine materialien mehr haben
und es ist glaube ich ganz entscheidend
damit wir es weiterhin bekommen die
krankenhäuser möglichst lange von der
flut der patienten zu entlasten damit
die sich um die wirklich schweren und
intensiv richtigen patienten kümmern
können muss die versorgung der
vertragsärzte stehen und das kann sie
nur wenn wir weiter
kontinuierlich mit schutzbekleidung
versorgt werden und dadurch keine praxen
vom netz gehen
professorin herold bitte ja sehr geehrte
damen und herren ich möchte ihnen aus
dem klinikalltag schildern die wir uns
aktuell vorbereiten als infektiologen an
der universität in gießen habe ich quasi
aktuell den lied das zu organisieren mit
meinen kollegen zusammen und das was ich
jetzt schildere ist denke ich
exemplarisch für viele große häuser für
unikliniken und auch für andere
maximalversorger das uniklinikum in
gießen hat mehrere normal stationen
jetzt komplett freigeräumt für
privatpatienten das heißt auch die idee
nicht intensiv wichtig sind brauchen ja
müssen ja entsprechend versorgt werden
und möglichst abgeschottet vom normalen
patienten betrieb da haben wir circa 70
betten jetzt in der maximalen
eskalationsstufe freie geschafft für und
das geht eben nur dann wenn die kliniken
ihr electric programm komplett
herunterfahren das bedeutet alles was
nicht gerade lebensnotwendig ist an
operationen aber auch ein ambulanz
besuchen wird im moment eingestellt oder
ist eingestellt worden
was die intensiv kapazitäten angelangt
hat sich das uniklinikum zum beispiel
jetzt hier 173 betten die sind
normalerweise zu über 90 prozent belegt
und wir haben es jetzt geschafft
insgesamt in der maximalen letzten
eskalationsstufe durch schaffung 40 von
40 weiteren zusätzlichen betten
insgesamt 113 beatmungs betten zu
schaffen für die patienten das ist ein
enormer aufwand nicht so sehr
problematisch was die betten angelangt
oder auch im moment noch nicht was
beatmungsgeräte selbst angelangt aber
natürlich ist es hoch personalintensiv
und deshalb müssen wir gucken wie wir
ein zusätzliches personal kommen das tun
wir im moment in dem wir kollegen wieder
einarbeiten die uns verlassen haben oder
die in elternzeit sind aber auch und
insbesondere rekrutieren wir
medizinstudenten und bilden derzeit an
beatmungsgeräten aus um uns da zu
unterstützen
das bedeutet aber auch dass wir die
infrastruktur in den kliniken deutlich
jetzt um ändern muss
das heißt wir haben sogar auch eine
eigene notfallstation für patienten die
mit rtw es angeliefert werden
eingerichtet wo erst mal bis queen wird
hat der patient vielleicht eine saß zwar
infektion oder nicht so dass also auch
die wegeführung in der kinderklinik
komplett getrennt ist zwischen nicht ko
wird und kuwait patienten das ist dass
wir auch unser hoch so ist aktive des
patienten klientel in den kliniken auch
schützen können vor weiteren infektionen
und eben auch dann eigene teams personal
teams etablieren können die nur solche
patienten behandeln und die dann
ausschließlich andere patienten
behandeln zunächst dann auch nochmal zu
den therapien
es gibt im moment verschiedene
therapiemöglichkeiten
das sind vor allem ich werde jetzt mal
den englischen begriff sogenannte
replacing strategien das heißt
medikamente die bereits in der anwendung
sind gegen andere infektionserkrankungen
werden getestet derzeit in klinischen
studien ob sie auch gegen korona viren
dagegen dass neue cabrios helfen dass es
insbesondere das chloroquin ein malaria
medikament aber auch das nokia wir ein
medikament was in der hiv medizin
angewendet wird und ein neues medikament
das initial getestet wurde für seine
effektivität gegen ebola aber
möglicherweise gegen korona viren sehr
gut helfen kann auch das ist das revier
und es gibt einen großen eine große
globale studie der whu der sogenannte
solidarität teil der jetzt in fünf
verschiedene namen vier
therapiestrategien testet gegen placebo
und da sind die genannten die ich eben
im landtag eben auch mit enthalten und
man sollte eben tatsächlich diese
medikamente jetzt auch wirklich nur in
klinischen studien einsetzen die finden
nicht nur weltweit statt sondern eben
auch lokal in deutschland
letzten endes muss man auch sagen das
ist natürlich viel forschungsaktivität
gibt ich bin auch jemand der
wissenschaftlich aktiv ist auf diesem
feld
da sind die deutschen gesundheitszentren
natürlich auch ganz vorne
ich spreche hier für das deutsche
zentrum für lungenforschung aber wir
sind auch mit dem dcf kollegen natürlich
in engem austausch und versuchen auch
ganz neue therapiestrategien jetzt im
patienten zu testen
es laufen zum beispiel studien oder eine
studie zu einem medikament was die
lokale immunität oder die immunabwehr
der lunge verbessert und gleichzeitig
versucht die regeneration der
geschädigten lunge im späten verlauf
wenn also schon jemand eine junge
versagen hat zu verbessern
und ja ich denke dass es da auch
natürlich dadurch dass das bmbf viel
fördergelder jetzt freigegeben hat für
solche forschungen dass es da auch
vielleicht ja einiger zeit gute
nachrichten geben wird vielen dank
und herr professor jens bitte ja meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren
schön dass wir hier als die dabei sein
dürfen wir freuen uns wirklich sehr und
können auch sagen das ist glaube ich die
intensivmediziner rinnen und sie
kritisieren in deutschland die worte
unserer region sehr ernst genommen haben
in den letzten wochen
frau professor herold hat ihnen das ja
schon dargestellt dass wirklich alle
kliniken soweit ich das jetzt auch
unseren verband überblicken kann
wirklich darauf reagiert haben die
kapazitäten umgeschichtet haben und das
ist es wirklich gelungen
das kann ich für meine schicksal für
andere kliniken auch in der region
kapazitäten frei zu schaufeln die
dringend benötigt werden im moment um
platz zu schaffen wir das was kommt und
sie hören jeden tag neue meldungen die
zahlen steigen posavina hat uns das ja
auch schon gesagt wir sind aber ganz
ganz besonders froh dass wir eigentlich
mit unserem ads netzwerk vor sardinien
ist letzter
führende vertreter schon früh an einer
plattform gearbeitet haben die uns ganz
spezielle verfahren dargestellt hat
sogar ein eck wo das der extrakorporalen
ersatz da haben es die kliniken diesen
spezialverfahren durchführen
auf einer plattform vereinigt und
stellen da wo die kapazitäten sind und
diese plattform haben wir auf die
initiative von poser wieder carstens und
dr mengen von der charité und herr ramm
heinrich vom rk ii benutzt das
aufzubauen und jetzt eine nationale
plattform zu schaffen das so genannte
die wie intensiv register was es jetzt
tatsächlich innerhalb kürzester zeit wir
sind erst seit anderthalb wochen am
start in die lage versetzt flächen
übergreifen deutschlandweit daten zu
erheben und zu schauen tatsächlich wo an
dieser stelle freie kapazitäten da sind
das ist wirklich das muss man sagen
weltweit einmalig das gibt es nirgendwo
die kliniken mittlerweile sind es glaube
ich 670 an der zahl sind leider gottes
noch nicht alle da werden wir vielleicht
noch drüber sprechen haben sich
eingeschrieben und geben da ihre betten
ein ihre kapazitäten
beratungskapazitäten und auch die
kapazitäten was dieses sehr invasive
verfahren betrifft und wir spielen das
live aus und jeder kann das mittlerweile
und das war uns besonders wichtig auch
jeder von ihnen kann sich das anschauen
und sieht dann auch mittlerweile weisen
work in progress ist auf landkarten in
deutschland tatsächlich in den einzelnen
bundesländern
wie viele freie kapazitäten dort sind an
intensivbetten wie viele patienten schon
an dieser stelle mit der corvette 19
erkrankung liegen und die kollegen
selber die sich dann einloggen in den
geschützten bereich kann dann sehr sehr
genau sehen in welcher gegend sie
tatsächlich wenn sie an ihre
kapazitätsgrenzen geraten sind
wo sie darüber auf freie betten verfügen
können und das ist wirklich einmalig und
wir sind auch sehr dankbar dass das
bundesministerium für gesundheit uns
dann wirklich auch unterstützt mit auch
know how mit
und das ist ein work in progress sie
können sich vorstellen in den letzten
wochen haben die kollegen wirklich
abends nächte lang zu sein
gesessen das weiterentwickelt und wir
sind auch wirklich begeistert dass und
auch stolz drauf dass es uns gelungen
ist welchen anfang mittlerweile aus
kanada aus auch england die sich dafür
interessieren dass wir so eine
transparente struktur schaffen
unser großer wunsch unserer große bitte
ist es gibt auch an den bundesminister
dann das dass tatsächlich alle kliniken
dabei sind wenn alle kliniken dabei sind
und das wäre sehr wichtig also wie es
jetzt appellieren wir ja quasi und
bitten darum sich einzuschreiben aber
die durchdringung ist noch nicht 100
prozent will sind so schätzungsweise bei
60 bis 70 prozent und damit noch mal
ganz gespannt wenn da so noch mal einen
schub kommt dann können wir mit 100
prozent am start genau sagen wo wir
stehen heute morgen kann ich ihnen sagen
haben wir in deutschland mit denen circa
60 prozent der kliniken dieser sinnfreie
intensivbetten 5600 wir können mit dem
datenbank zeigen dass wir in den
nächsten 24 stunden noch zusätzliche
5700 intensivbetten freimachen können da
können sie ungefähr abschätzen 60 bis 70
prozent davon beratungskapazitäten also
wir sind im augenblick heute morgen und
übermorgen sicherlich gerüstet und mit
dieser plattform wenn sie weil sie ist
wirklich ganz nah an der zeit dann
können wir auch in die zukunft gucken
und können dann auch planung das ist
glaube ich für uns in der
intensivmedizin für alle die da in den
krankenhäusern arbeit aber auch für die
gesundheitsämter und herr wieland den
hat das auch sehr interessieren wir
unterstützen sie auch dass er ihn freut
dass auch das wäre so eine gute struktur
schaffen konnten und wir blicken jetzt
ganz gespannt in den nächsten tag und
werden dann sehen wie die betten dann
sich verändern ob wir dann noch so viele
freie betten haben
ich will hoffen dass das zunächst mal so
stabil bleibt das würde bedeuten dass
wenn mich zum dramatischen anstieg haben
wie in anderen regionen vielen dank
vielen dank ihnen wir haben jetzt rund
25 minuten zeit für fragen das ist ein
tropfen auf dem heißen stein ministerin
fleckner minister steuer waren so
freundlich und so flexibel in der
viertelstunde nach hinten zu verschieben
die kommen
gegen 13 uhr 45 und ich fange mal hier
im saal an frau kollegin bitte lisa
braun presseagentur gesundheit ich habe
zwei fragen ich mache es ganz schnell
eine frage geht an den minister herr
minister wie wann und wo gibt es denn
ein überblick über die
beschaffungsmaßnahmen was waren rein
kommt und was wie verteilt wird und
direkt die nächste frage die geht glaube
ich auch einen dr
an herrn dr gassen es gibt für mich ein
widerspruch vielleicht können sie das
mal auflösen oder besser erklären auf
der einen seite wird gesagt es wird viel
zu viel getestet allem hat die zahlen
ausgedrückt das sind akkreditierte
labore die haben die zahl rausgebracht
das zehn weniger als zehn prozent
positiv getestet wurden das heißt also
das ist alles nicht so richtig indiziert
war was da von den ärzten gerade
verordnet wurde unter anderen seite wird
gesagt dass es aber gutes dass wir
getestet haben also was ist denn jetzt
eigentlich richtig also so ganz
erschließt sich mehr brauchen ich würde
sagen beide ist es richtig viel aber
zielgerichteter ist unser ziel über und
viel testen wir wollen zielgerichteter
testen denn sie haben recht übrig sie
zahlen das waren ja gerade die zahlen
von den ganzen aus dem niedergelassenen
ärztlichen bereich haben zusätzlich die
uni labore den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst so dass wir eine
kapazität von gut 300.000 tests in der
woche jetzt schon auch haben dürften die
durchgeführt werden
aber sie haben recht die positiv testung
ist dabei um die zehn prozent im schnitt
gewesen
und das ist tatsächlich ein indiz dafür
dass es zielgerichteter ginge das ist
genau der grund auch warum eben in den
letzten tagen
wer die kriterien überarbeitet worden
überarbeitet worden sind das heißt aber
auch und das ist ja die aufgabe und das
ist ja das weswegen auch so dankbar bin
das vergessen und der weder darauf
hingewiesen haben dass wir unseren
bürgerinnen und bürgern eben auch sagen
müssen um verständnis bitten müssen
werden müssen wenn ich verstehe dass
also eine unsicherheit heraus viele
sagen ich würde aber gerne wissen
wenn aber keine symptome vorliegen
kein kontakt zu jemandem der positiven
risikogebiet dann ist ein test nicht
angezeigt und das müssen wir glaube ich
auch vermitteln dass aus der
unsicherheit heraus die nachvollziehbar
ist wer gleichzeitig aus der begrenzten
kapazität heraus
eben nicht jeden testen können deswegen
war mir eben diese informationen hier
auch noch sehr sehr wichtig zur frage
der schutzausrüstung habe ich eines
gelernt in den letzten tagen über zahlen
erst reden wenn sie gelandet sind hier
bei uns in deutschland
ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können dass
in einem bereich wo es mal um
centbeträge gegen sie müssen mal sehen
diese masken haben mal sechs cent 16
cent die anderen gekostet dass wir da im
moment eher eine solche lage auf der
welt hinein kommen wo wir über 3 56 euro
zum teil für zwei masten also die etwas
mehr schützenden entweder für die
testung auch reden das ist ein
wahnsinnig umkämpfter markt gerade die
preise gehen hoch und runter wie haben
am goldmarkt oder wie immer sie es
wollen und das ist sehr herausfordernd
wir sind aber zuversichtlich dass wir
mit anderen herangehensweise und neuen
partnern jetzt schrittweise die dinge
tatsächlich eine bessere richtung
bringen
es sind in den letzten tagen täglich
masken ausgeliefert worden die mengen
sind so dass die ärzte zu recht sagen es
muss noch mehr sein aber mir war wichtig
dass wir tatsächlich jeden tag jetzt
auch wäre das nicht auch eine große
zahlen erst mal warten und dann so
sondern lieber jeden tag und dafür aber
jetzt erstmal die versorgung hinein und
dass wir das dann jetzt auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter erhöhen und wenn
das alles gelandet ist was ich erwarte
dass es landet dann sage ich ihnen die
zahlen ja vielleicht noch gefragt und
ich würde das gerne noch ergänzen die
frage von frauen mit einer frage online
von gregor waschinski vom handelsplatz
welche möglichkeiten bieten schnelltests
also wir haben sogar noch mehr kapazität
ration ist gerade einmal blieben
wahrscheinlich bei 360.000 es pro woche
die frage verbauen warum ändert man ist
das regime wir haben ja anfangs wir mit
der maßgabe rang möglichst umfänglich
ein bild über die zahl der infektionen
zu bekommen und 6,8 prozent ist über
alle die positiv quote in den
in belasteten regionen ist ja auch höher
deutlich über zehn prozent erleben aber
länder die testen und die haben sie sind
alle positiv weil die testen die ganzen
kranken wenn sie nach italien schauen
wir haben also wahrscheinlich hier in
deutschland die situation dass wir durch
die sehr frühen testung die eben auch
ein zur verfügung stand es gab kein
erstattungspreis in den usa müssen die
patienten das selber zahlen deshalb
haben sie höchst fragmentierte
testergebnisse wir haben also ein recht
umfängliches bild über die zahl an test
und irgendwann mit den zahlen der
positiven und wir hoffen dadurch die
dunkelziffer relativ gering zwar nur
geringer als die flächen anderen ländern
während es wird eine geben aber
vielleicht sie nicht ganz so hoch zu den
schnell zu den test dieser am point of
care wahrscheinlich jetzt gefragt ob wir
diesen automatisierten tests jetzt
gerade gesprochen wird wenn sie die test
kapazität von 360.000 im moment in der
woche ergänzt um die universitären
labore die wir da nicht haben die so in
der unihalle was habe ich 250 am tag
also das sind auch ein paar tausend die
dazu kommen dann hat dieser point of
care tests den charts war dass sie ihn
sozusagen in der praxis machen können er
macht aber einen test pro person der
dauert zweieinhalb stunden jetzt können
sie das sehr schnell hochrechnen wie
viel von diesen maschinen sie bräuchten
um auf dieses kapazität zu kommen das
ist also sicherlich nicht das was uns
die an den punkt jetzt hilft das ist ein
test der auch andere erkältungsviren
abgreift ich glaube dass wir mit den
labortest deutlich höheren durchsatz
gewährleisten können aber eine
ergänzende maßnahme mag ist durchaus
sein und zu den masken auch das hat der
minister schon gesagt wir haben es wäre
sicherlich schön wenn es 20 millionen
masken auf dem hof stehen hätten aber so
lang jeden tag einige hunderttausend
kommen ist das ausreichend die das darf
er nie abreißen und ich habe allerdings
den eindruck dass wir tatsächlich so
langsam das ganze in tritt kommt die
lieferwege sind jetzt lange etwas
eingespielter und es gehe noch zunimmt
wieder produzenten an die arbeit so dass
wir hoffen dass das kein primäres
problem mehr sein wird so welt die wir
nicht ganz gut sagt für den schnelltest
habe ganz viel ich gehe jeden tag
hunderte e-mails wo sie heute sagen aus
china millionen schnelltest jetzt kaufen
und unser instituts unserem de femmes
bundes
institut für arzneimittel
medizinprodukte die testet die ja auch
und schaut sich hier an und die sind
halt nicht sensitive und spezifische
doch es bringt uns nichts wenn wir
schnell tests haben die falsch positive
oder falsch negative in großer zahl sind
sobald wir einen schnelltest haben der
gut ist werden wir ihn einsetzen aber
solange er nicht gut ist
bleiben wir bei den verfahren die wir
haben ein konkretes also her gebrauchen
sagt dass möglicherweise die schüler
schülerinnen zuerst zum ersten finde ich
es immer wichtig dass wir jetzt auch
erstmal in den botschaften klar sind
jetzt geht es darum auch das was wir an
maßnahmen die bundesländer die kommunen
beschlossen haben durchsetzen jetzt auch
durchzuhalten
ich finde es sehr wichtig dass die
botschaft klar bleibt sie können dann
nach ostern möglicherweise über eine
veränderung reden wenn wir bis ostern
alle miteinander konsequenz sind der
teil ist wichtig weil eben diese
verlangsamung ja gelingen muss erst
einmal und ob sie gelingt werden wir
erst in ein paar tagen in der statistik
sehen es ist ja immer zeitversetzt
professor wieder 10 14 tage bestimmt bis
sich die dinge vollends bemerkbar machen
es sind ja auch manche so ungeduldig und
sagen es gilt auch jetzt schon drei tage
warum sich sehen wir noch nichts also es
braucht jetzt ein paar tage bis wir
etwas sehen und jetzt umso mehr wer das
jetzt gemeinsam durchhalten und zwar
auch aus einsicht wir werden ja auch mit
hashtag wir bleiben zu hause als
ministerium mit vielen anderen dafür
dass tatsächlich auch nicht nur als
sozusagen verpflichtung gesetzlich oder
staatlich zu sehen sondern auch
möglichst aus einsicht mitzumachen weil
es eben uns alle schützt
wenn wir das schaffen dann können wir
nach ostern über andere perspektiven
drehen aber es ist die voraussetzung das
finde ich noch mal wichtig einfach in
der kommunikation und dann geht s
tatsächlich natürlich darum dann die
frage wie man gezielt testet wir werden
definitiv weiterhin sehr umfasst
testen müssen wir werden sehr intensiv
der weiß professor wähler immer
daraufhin fortwährend kontakt
nachverfolgung machen müssen so bald
positiv testung da ist sofort alle
kontakte identifizieren
es geht um die frage von
therapieoptionen ob wir in zwei oder
vier wochen schlauer sind als wir heute
sind es geht um die frage eben auch
schutzkonzepte zu haben für bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen die besonders
gefährdet sind und das alles
zusammenzuführen
daran arbeiten wir im bundesministerium
für gesundheit mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen mit hochdruck und zwischen
jetzt und ostern werden wir es ihnen
sicherlich auch noch mal im
gesamtkonzept präsentieren können
fragten auch volker schmidt denker von
rtl und war kristall nicht vom ard
hörfunk ich würde gerne das noch
ergänzen mit der frage von sascha meyer
von db a
ob es einen schlüssel indikator dafür
gibt ab wann man mit den kontakt
beschränkungen oder ab wann man die
kontakt beschränkungen lockern könnte
dass die infizierten zahl ist dass die
krankenhaus bewegung also dass das ist
ja eine epidemie in einem ausmaß wie sie
bislang noch nicht kannten und es sind
natürlich alle diese zahlen die wir
haben das heißt es sind indikatoren das
sind die krankenhaus beleben sind die
krankenzahlen das ist die die gesamte
last an infektion aber wir werden das
alles beobachten und analysieren
entscheidend ist dass uns diese daten
zur verfügung stehen und wie sie
auswerten können welche von den faktoren
an welche rolle spielen werden wir sehen
wir können es momentan nicht genau sagen
aber der entscheidende punkt ist wir
werden alle diese daten kontinuierlich
auswerten und daraus unsere schlüsse
ziehen und darum brauchen wir diese
informationen und daten
und darum ist es zum beispiel wichtig
dass wir unsere ressourcen optimal
einsetzen
und wenn wir wissen dass die ressourcen
optimal eingesetzt werden dann wissen
wir dass es nur noch an den anderen
schlüssel indikator liegt aber wir
müssen erstmal das ganze potenzial heben
und das wurde sehr schön dargestellt wie
wichtig es ist zu steuern
bei der patientenversorgung aber eben
auch bei den testungen damit wir
wirklich strategisch alles optimal
einsetzen können und dann schauen wir
uns die zahlen an und werden daraus
unsere schlüsse ziehen
vor der eigentlichen frage hier nochmal
eine nachfrage heißt es dass eigentlich
die grundvoraussetzungen dieser
lockerung ist dass man die kontakte von
infizierten nachvollziehen kann sehen
wir gerade im infektionsschutzgesetz
jetzt die ortung der handydaten nicht
durchsetzen können dabei ist das eine
voraussetzung dafür dass man überhaupt
zu einer lockerung kommt ihrer meinung
nach
und das zweite richtet sich auf die zum
personal
es gibt ja nun beschränkungen dass
pflegekräfte aus osteuropa nicht mehr
hier einreisen können aus tschechien zum
beispiel auf ärztliches personal saison
arbeiter ist ein anderes thema aber es
zeigt nur dass es eben zunehmend
schwierig ist das überhaupt
arbeitskräfte nach deutschland gelangen
wie gefährlich ist das eigentlich für
die behandlung von infizierten
ich fange mal mit letzterem an ihr
zuerst die frage von osteuropäischen
pflegekräften ärzten ist nicht das
problem dass wir sie sozusagen nicht
einreisen ließen sondern ist eher die
frage ob andere länder sie ausreisen
lassen und zweitens die frage ob sie sie
wieder zurückkehren lassen in ihr
heimatland werden sie in deutschland
waren in der frage geben ob sie denn in
quarantäne müssen oder nicht
deswegen sind wir auf allen ebenen der
bundesregierung auch in gesprächen mit
unseren kollegen in den ländern wie wir
das gewährleisten können wir ein spüren
das gilt übrigens für den warenverkehr
wie eben auch für die frage der
freizügigkeit auch bei der berufswahl an
den grenzen aber auch für den
warenverkehr
es geht jetzt nicht nur für die für den
medizinbereich aber da geht es auch
besonders bei arzneimittel
medizinprodukte beatmungsgerät bei allen
was wir brauchen jeden tag das gilt für
alle lebensbereiche sind wir sehr
voneinander abhängig in europa und zwar
nicht einseitig abhängig sondern
wirklich gegenseitig abhängig
voneinander in den lieferketten und dem
austausch und deswegen ist der freie
warenverkehr gerade in dieser zeit
wichtiger denn je in einer zeit wo wir
im zweifel uns nicht mehr so sehr auf
andere weltregionen verlassen können
dass da immer alles so kommt wie wir es
gewohnt sind deswegen werde ich wo ich
immer ich kann auch in europa bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen erstens für
freien warenverkehr werben
und zweitens auch dass wir insbesondere
eben zur berufsausübung auch dort das
möglich machen über die grenze schlicht
und ergreifend zu kommen zu pendeln
aber eben auch hier entsprechend arbeit
verrichten zu können das ist sehr sehr
wichtig für das gesundheitswesen ist
aber auch sehr wird sehr wichtig für
unsere versorgung insgesamt in
deutschland erste frage das was es in
jedem fall braucht sind konzepte die
auch tatsächlich funktionieren auch von
der in den ressourcen auf personal
ressourcen die sie brauchen weiter
intensiv nach zu verfolgen solange wir
keine keinen impfstoff haben und keine
sozusagen sehr klare gute therapie die
die schwersten verläufe sehr schnell in
den griff wohl gar nicht erst gar nicht
entstehen lässt und die auch
flächendeckend verfügbar wäre
müssen wir infektionsgeschehen
schnellstmöglich immer unterbrechen es
ist ein hoch infektiös virus im
rachenraum und deswegen ist es dann
wichtig bei jedem der positiv getesteten
ist sehr sehr schnell kontakt
nachzuvollziehen und auch die
kontaktpersonen eben häuslich zu
isolieren wie das heißt also
aufzufordern für zwei wochen zu hause zu
bleiben
das können sie händisch machen indem sie
hinterher telefonieren abfragen und die
dinge nachvollziehen oder das können sie
auf anderen wegen machen und wir merken
dass das händische jedenfalls an
kapazitätsgrenzen schlicht und
ergreifend kommt im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und dem
gesundheitssystem instrument noch nicht
vorwurfsvoll die kolleginnen kollegen
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst sind
gerade rund um die uhr im einsatz und
leisten großartiges und das auch klar
und deutlich zu sagen aber wenn die zahl
in groß ist dass kontakt nachverfolgen
händisch schwierig das stellt dann die
frage wie sie aufgeworfen haben ob es
effizientere wege gibt weil ohne kontakt
nachverfolgen bei einzelnen infektion
wird es nicht gehen
dann gibt es andere die frage von kai
biermann die zeit die zeit online wie
wird entschieden welche behandlungen
bei patienten mit anderen akuten
krankheiten nicht mehr vorgenommen
werden
gibt es einschränkungen bei der
versorgung für die übrigen krankheiten
ist es ist versteht sich von selber das
kogit 19 patienten sahne oder nicht mit
90 patienten nach den gleichen kriterien
behandelt werden dringlichkeits
kriterien und da machen wir auch und
bitten auch alle kollegen und
kolleginnen das auch zu tun
behandelt werden da werden auch
keinerlei unterschiede gemacht der
akuten myokardinfarkt die akute schwere
herzschwäche die akute schwere atemnot
bei einem chronischen versagen wird
natürlich genauso behandelt und genügt
den gleichen kriterien zum einbringen in
die intensivtherapie wie ein qubit 19
patienten da dürfen auch kein
unterschied gemacht wenn da müssen auch
sehr besonders darauf achten dass genau
in diesen zeiten die bevölkerung auch
genau weiß und sie kann sich auch sicher
sein dass die akute versorgung an der
stelle genau so weiter fortgeführt wird
vorher rollt ich glaube das sehen sie
genauso absolut ja wir müssen gucken
dass die leute nicht nur nicht an gruner
sterben sondern eben auch nicht wegen
kerner
das ist ganz wichtig und natürlich
werden keine tumor operation oder alles
was lebensnotwendig ist rettung von poly
traumata und so weiter das wird
natürlich genau so weiterlaufen wie
bisher
frage an herrn viele sie bekommen dem
loben auch gerade viel kritik am
institut wie gehen sie mit dieser kritik
umgehen als ab oder nervt sie das und
vielleicht können sie ganz kurz
schildern unter welcher belastung ihr
haus gerade steht ich vermute mal dass
sie und ihre mitarbeiter gerade auch
nicht viel schlaf bekommen danke er hat
vielen dank wo licht ist ist auch
schatten
ich war das damit muss man leben wichtig
ist dass unser haus arbeiten kann ja
wichtig ist dass meine mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiter den vollen support kriegen
das ist eine schwere zeit für uns aber
das ist für alle die hier oben sitzende
schwer bezahlen und in unserem land gibt
es ganz viele menschen die druck haben
und unter bestimmten bedingungen
arbeiten
damit müssen wir umgehen machen wir uns
immer wieder für uns ist wirklich
wichtig dass wir die information
erhalten und dass wir die informationen
so analysieren können dass wir allen
empfehlungen geben können dass wir mit
dieser krise so gut wie möglich umgehen
das ist der entscheidende punkt das ist
jetzt die zeit
das ist derzeit das ist keine zeit für
die elefanten ist eine zeit für profis
ja und da muss man diese dinge eben
durch stehen das werden wir tun
hinterher können wir über alles reden
und und gibt es eine generalabrechnung
aber im moment ist das nicht möglich
echtes nur ergänzen was ich erlebe ist
dass kollegen auch aus europäischen
nachbarländern geradezu nachfragen aktiv
nach der expertise des
robert-koch-instituts wir haben ein
international und europäisch sehr
angesehenes institut hier für die
öffentliche gesundheit als
bundesrepublik deutschland der professor
wähler und ich hab in der vergangenheit
schon öfter darüber gesprochen wie wir
es noch weiter stärken können und ich
denke die notwendigkeit zu über die wir
uns immer einig waren es weiter zu
stärken
die ist jetzt noch präsent dabei fielen
ich hoffe dass wir das auch anschließend
mitnehmen in der stärkung des institutes
und des öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes
in der vernetzung des robert koch
institutes mit den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes vor ort aber das
ansehen dass das robert koch institut
international und europäisch hat das
spüren wir gerade auch in dieser zeit
weil die expertise auch nachgefragt
initiative von der zeitung herr spahn
eine gute nachfrage haben sich richtig
verstanden dass die äußerung von
kanzleramtsminister brown über die leute
die als erste wieder raus könnten für
sie zur unzeit kommen und einfach zu
früh
und dann fragen an die fachleute an
herrn professor janssen und an frau
professor ihr wollt wir haben jetzt
gehört das materialien unterwegs sein
wir sind aber alle hier und warten ja
eigentlich noch auf dem weg von dem wir
nicht wissen wie groß er wird können sie
beschreiben wie lange ihre krankenhäuser
durchhalten bis wieder masken da sind
bis wieder gesichtsschutz da ist also
augen schutzmasken schutz da ist und
auch ganz einfach schutzkleidung wie
lange halten sie wenn es ansatzweise
wird wie in italien oder in spanien
deutlich weniger lange halten sie
eigentlich durch ja das kann nicht
beantworten
bei dem durch sehen wir im moment haben
reicht es im moment für zwei wochen
es hat aber eine lieferung nach hessen
gegeben die wurde zuerst einmal im
bereich der kv verteilt weil da der
allergrößte nied war in der tat aber wir
rechnen jetzt in den nächsten tagen mit
weiteren lieferungen kriegen auch
kleinere lieferungen schon wieder von
anbietern und ja hoffen dass wir damit
dann nachdem zwei wochen auch wieder
ausgestattet ist das bei zwei wochen
sowie betrieb jetzt oder zwei wochen
anstieg es ist schon kalkuliert für
betrieb jetzt allerdings muss ich sagen
wir haben ihnen diesen 113
intensivbetten die wir frei halten
maximal im moment drei beatmete
patienten also es ist noch wenig wir
erwarten jetzt nicht dass es morgen 30
oder 40 sind das heißt es wird ja
langsam ansteigen deshalb das werden
sich diese kurven jetzt überschneiden
aber ja ich kann es
dazu steuern in der tat diese 14 tage 10
bis 14 tage in diesem zeitraum arbeiten
wir das viel auf mit viel fantasie auch
daran gearbeitet worden uns gelingt das
auch in den etwas kleineren häusern da
hinterher zu kommen und ich denke auch
wir haben auch ressourcen schonend
arbeiten wir auch wir haben tatsächlich
auch die empfehlungen die zunächst
relativ streng waren wie häufig wie
lange darf ich eine bestimmte masse
können wir jetzt auch nach der
bestimmung auch noch empfehlungen
beispielsweise das lka koch instituts
und der charité die auch mit vollgas
meyer da wirklich sehr gute empfehlung
entwickelt hat das haben wir jetzt auch
von der divi aufgenommen und genau
diesem punkt auf den krankenhäuser zur
verfügung gestellt dass wir tatsächlich
sagen okay wir wissen dass wir jetzt
eine cool so 'ne shortage arm eine
knappheit haben wir gehen ganz bewusst
in bestimmten bereichen nicht mehr mit
den tollen masken ran sondern gehen mit
dem normalen mund nasen schutz den sie
überall hier in berlin sehen versorgen
die patienten adäquat die nicht
besonders gefährdet sind
die erosion bildende produktion
hervorzurufen
da können wir schon ganz schön ab
differenzieren in dem verbrauch der
schutzausrüstung da sind ganz wichtige
punkte er hilft uns auch lokal genau
diese zeit zu überbrücken bis danach der
richtige schub kommt und wir hoffen
wirklich dass es so sein wird der
mindestlohn liegt ja schon fast nahezu
hat er eben gesagt er warte noch drauf
und er kann ihnen auch glaube ich keine
zahlen sagen aber im moment zehn bis 14
tage kurze antwort ist nein
und wer professor brauchen und ich
schätze die dinge sehr sehr gleich ein
ich hab die seine aussage so eingeordnet
wie er sie selber auch eingeordnet hätte
da bin ich sehr sicher eine frage an
professor janssen sie sind ja mit autor
dieser handreichung für die behandlung
von intensivpatienten könnten sie noch
einmal das ethische probleme schildern
wenn die zahl der fälle so steigt das
nicht alle gleichzeitig mit der nötigen
behandlung behandelt werden können ja
vielen dank für die frage ich glaube sie
beziehen sich auf das gerade ganz
aktuell publizierte paper was ja
eigentlich vor circa zehn tagen muss man
mal sagen in den blick genommen haben
weil uns natürlich schon die bilder aus
italien spanien und andere regionen sehr
bewegt haben unter welchem druck
ärztinnen und ärzte pflegepersonal
tatsächlich in den patienten abt
reagieren muss tatsächlich
entscheidungen und zwar treffen mussten
die tatsächlich den tod von patienten zu
fahren haben das sind ganz kritische
themen
wir haben sagt wir müssen uns und unsere
erst ärzte in deutschen genau auf dieses
thema vorbereitet und ist uns gelungen
mit einer ganz breiten mannschaft
nämlich ethikern juristen intensiv
minister dann eigentlich diese sehr
schöne diese haben sagt andré empfehlung
zu formulieren die als erster schritt
als work in progress gilt das wenn und
wir haben dann wenn es so kommen sollte
wie die zahlen was ich im moment nichts
sehe ganz bewusst sondern dass wir aber
vorbereitet sind und mit diesen
empfehlungen die ich nicht ganz in der
tiefe darstellen kann bin ich mir aber
ganz sicher dass wir da eine ganz große
hilfe geschaffen haben dass wir
sicherheit schaffen auf der seite der
behandler mit dieser extrem schweren
entscheidungen professionell umzugehen
und auch die richtige entscheidung zu
treffen ja und keiner braucht angst zu
haben in deutschland das hier
entscheidungen mit dem daumen rauf und
runter gemacht werden ganz im gegenteil
und wir haben auch nicht nur das leicht
ganz bewusst an dieser stelle das alter
als alleiniges entscheidungskriterium
gewählt weil uns das zu kurz gegriffen
scheint sondern wir gehen ganz in die
tiefe und schauen uns an wie die
patienten die therapie benötigen
tatsächlich begleiter kann sind was
sonst noch für faktoren vorlegen und ich
glaube das schafft sicherheit und das
ist ganz wichtig im augenblick für
unsere kolleginnen kollegen vor auch
dass sie genau das jetzt schon mal haben
und wir entwickeln das übrigens weiter
weil wir haben das online gestellt und
haben es noch nicht publiziert sondern
mit dem tool können kolleginnen kollegen
ihre meinungen einbringen und dann
können wir das entwickeln und werden da
ganz engmaschig auch neue publikationen
dazu und verbesserungen einbringen
jordans hat elected letzte frage ja
meine frage nachfrage an vergessens zu
den test zahlen sie haben von 250 bis
260 gesprochen das ist eine differenz zu
dem halbe millionen die heute auch schon
erwähnt worden
testet sonst noch jemand etwas die
differenzen gibt es dann eine gesamtzahl
der test seit ende januar die bisher
geführt wurden und dr
aus ihrer klinischen erfahrung wir haben
eigentlich habe er gesehen wie spanien
oder italien sind sie zuversichtlich
dass so etwas in deutschland nicht
passieren wird sind der bitte um eine
kurze antwort und dem blick auf die uhr
zum einen haben wir natürlich im
wesentlichen die vertragsärztlichen und
bei uns gemeldeten festung im auge zwar
muss man sagen die kapazitäten sind auch
erhöht wollen weil viele labore auf die
groß durchsatz maschinen umgestiegen
sind in den letzten wochen dadurch sind
die kapazitäten deutlich erhöht worden
wir liegen also im moment im vertrag
sind manchmal knapp 400.000 test
ich beantworte mal die zweite frage
sie wissen alle dass wir jetzt keine
klare tredition machen können aber ich
vielleicht im vergleich zu italien jetzt
wir haben gerade gehört wie die
kapazität unserer freien intensivbetten
ist für diese erkrankung das sind schon
mehr als in ganz italien eigentlich
vorhanden sind
ich glaube wir sind da sehr gut
aufgestellt wir hatten jetzt das glück
dass wir eine sehr lange vorbereitungs
periode hatten wirklich alle hier leute
ein trainieren am ventilator und so
weiter neue geräte bestellen und
wirklich uns aufrüsten und dezidierte
pläne machen die dann auch funktionieren
können und nicht innerhalb kurzer zeit
irgendwie agieren müssen deshalb glaube
ich dass wir mit diesem vorteil und mit
unserer breiten testmöglichkeit deutlich
besser dastehen als in den ländern wo es
jetzt wirklich schlimm verläuft wenn wir
mal nach new york city gucken zum
beispiel oder wie sie gesagt haben
italien und so weiter ich glaube dass
wir gut aufgestellt ich habe ein gutes
gefühl dass wir das stemmen können
abschließend sagen darf keiner von uns
weiß wie sich die nächsten wochen
entwickeln uns immer die momentaufnahme
jetzt was mir noch mal sehr bewusst
geworden ist einfach in den letzten
wochen ist die stärke unseres
gesundheitssystems bei allen problemen
die wir im alltag haben und allen
problemen die sie beschreiben können wie
ich beschreiben kann den
alltagserfahrungen jetzt wo dinge unter
stress nicht so laufen wie sie sollten
und all den problemen die letzten zwei
drei vier fünf jahre immer gesprochen
haben aber gleichzeitig zu sehen was für
laborkapazitäten wir in diesem jahr
haben wie kein anderes land auf der welt
intensiv kapazitäten fachkräfte ärzte
pflegekräfte in einem umfang und in
einer auch bereitschaft wie ist das in
wenigen anderen ländern gibt und
manchmal bitte ich einfach auch die
deutschen zu sehen wenn es bei uns schon
schwierig wird an manchen stellen ein
gefühl dafür zu behalten
wie schwierig ist wahrscheinlich in
anderen ländern in dieser lage mit
dieser epidemie werden wird ich glaube
dass ganz wichtig das lässt einen
nämlich auch demütig bleiben
auch das zu sehen bei allen problemen
die wir in deutschland haben herzlichen
dank für diesen donnerstag mittag wir
räumen jetzt schnell auf und dann
erwarten wir die ministerin fleckner und
weniger vielen dank